♪ Bli bop zoo-vi, ♪
♪ zi ve bop zou-vou ♪
♪ J'l'ai rencontrée
au dépanneur ♪
- À l'été 1993, le Québec tombe
amoureux de Julie et d'un
nouveau groupe: Les Colocs.
♪ Ah wô wô wô, ma p'tite Julie ♪
♪ Si t'étais pas si jeune ♪
♪ J't'aurais pris ♪
Mike Gauthier était
au lancement du premier album
des Colocs, au New Orleans,
devenu le Club soda.
MIKE GAUTHIER,
animateur et journaliste
- Quand j'avais vu ça, j'avais
dit  : "C'est qui ce band-là!"
Et ils s'étaient déjà fait
remarquer lorsqu'il y avait eu
l'Empire de futures stars,
on les avait remarqués parce que
tu sais, ils étaient bons live,
Les Colocs.
♪ un mauvais quart d'heure ♪
♪ ah ah ah ah ♪
Entre les Québécois et
Les Colocs, c'est le coup
de foudre.
- Et là, tu as ce vent
de fraîcheur, qui arrive avec
l'album, puis "Julie" qui jouait
à la radio comme ça se peut pas.
GENEVIÈVE BORNE, animatrice
- C'est des arrangements
de fanfare, c'est très enjoué,
ça se danse, C'est très, très
joyeux. Donc le premier contact
qu'on a avec Les Colocs, c'est
la joie, malgré le fait qu'il
dénonce beaucoup d'injustices
sociales, on est dans la fête.
♪ Ben passe-moé à puck pis
j4vas en compter des buts! ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le groupe détonne avec
la variété pop mielleuse qui
joue à la radio au Québec
à l'époque et propose
un son plus inspiré du grunge.
- Nirvana qui était arrivé avec
Pearl Jam, tu sais en '91-'92,
tu sais, t'avais vraiment
cette grande vague de rock-là,
contestataire, un cri d'une
génération qui voulait être
entendue puis tout ça.
♪ Bonyeu, donne-moé une job ♪
♪ Pis j'te jure que j'vas
m'caser ♪
- Dédé est dans cet esprit-là
avec ses chansons,
la dénonciation : "Donnez-nous
une chance, faites-nous
un place".
- Malgré des textes engagés,
Les Colocs réussissent à toucher
le vaste public.
- C'était un peu
intergénérationnel, ça aussi, tu
sais, c'était pas un style
musical défini, c'était pas
du rock, c'était
pas un style, c'était comme...
tout le monde peut apprécier ça.
♪ Tassez-vous de d'là, y faut
que j'voye mon chum ♪
♪ Ça fait longtemps que j'l'ai
pas vu ♪
♪ Y était parti, y était
pas là ♪
- Puis ils étaient endossé par
l'industrie, je pense qu'au Gala
de l'ADISQ qui a suivi
la parution de leur premier
album, ils ont tout raflés, là.
- Bien, merci beaucoup à toute
l'équipe qui a travaillé
sur "Julie".
♪ Balma balma sama wadji ♪
♪ Khadjalama yonwi ♪
- Au fil des ans, les membres
du groupe ont changé, au fil
des influences et des sonorités
que Dédé souhaitait intégrer
au son des Colocs.
- C'était vraiment le Québécois
pure laine du Lac Saint-Jean
hyper ouvert sur le monde
et sur les culture et ça,
ça représentait un Québec
des années '90 qui s'ouvrait
vraiment sur le monde.
- Les Colocs, c'est aussi
un look et une esthétique.
Dédé Fortin avait d'ailleurs
étudié le cinéma.
- À chaque fois qu'on recevait
un nouveau clip des Colocs,
c'était un bijou, c'était hyper
complexe, léché, minutieux,
puis ça donnait toujours quelque
chose de très original comme
le clip pour "Julie".
- C'était souriant la musique
des Colocs, c'était souriant,
tu pouvais pas bougonner
en écoutant Les Colocs.
♪ C'est à cause
de mon répondeur ♪
- Une joie apparente, qui
contrastait avec la réalité
plus sombre de Dédé Fortin.
- Le chanteur rock André Fortin
est mort.
- Le choc a été immense quand
Dédé Fortin nous a quittés.
Immense. C'était un gars
extrêmement aimé et, non,
je pense que la population ne
soupçonnait pas à quel point ce
gars-là était malheureux,
vivait une détresse.
♪ Ah wô wô wô, ma p'tite Julie ♪
♪ Si t'étais pas si jeune ♪
♪ J't'aurais pris ♪
(sanglots)
- 30 ans plus tard, "Julie"
et Les Colocs, n'ont pas pris
une ride.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ Dis-toi que j't'un gars
patient ♪
♪ Pis viens me r'voir quand
t'auras vingt ans ♪
♪ Bi li tibibop tilibipop po
poup ♪
♪